oh
push push push stressing out
a [ __ ] ton of money in this video i saw
1 000 original ideas collected over the
past six years online to one person sold
for a lot of zeros
i wish i could tell you the amount but
that would ruin the entire thrill of
this video but most importantly i will
be giving the entire amount of money
made from selling this art piece within
this video
to someone who shares this video
subscribes to my channel turns on your
notifications bell
likes and
comments that you've done so below
yeah
my intent with this video is not to make
money i already have great sponsors that
help me make these videos so anything
above and beyond that i would love to
share with you and speaking of this wild
story of ups downs and many zeros is
sponsored by skillshare which is an
online learning community with thousands
of classes and members across 150
different countries around the world but
i'll tell you more about that later okay
blockchain crypto nfts i know absolutely
nothing about this [ __ ] i've never been
for it or against it so i've decided to
in four days learn what an nft is make a
really meaningful nft and then auction
it off starting the bidding at zero
hoping it matches what it would go for
in the real world like outside of the
nft space
basically for me as a filmmaker
this is possibly a new income stream
not just for filmmakers but for all
kinds of creatives
is the juice
[Music]
i've been to my eye
worth the squeeze
i think that's orange
firstly i watched the course on
skillshare about what an nft is and
whatnot
[Music]
and here's a quick explainer animation
of the knowledge i extracted from it nft
or non-funchable token is a digital
asset usually an image video or audio
file that's assigned a unique code in a
process called minting this code sits on
a blockchain which is like a public
digital ledger that records who minted
the file and who owns it
non-funchable means that a token can't
be interchanged with another
money for example is fungible if i trade
one dollar for another i essentially
still have the same thing but i can't
trade the mona lisa for a pokemon card
and call it the mona lisa so we call it
non-fungible nfts are a way to own art
in the online space and make money from
it by hard coding in a royalty amount so
that every time your art is sold you get
a percentage as commission
step one the mint
so i've been in the creative world as a
film director then youtuber and now like
some kind of hybrid for over the past 10
years and i've been fortunate enough to
collaborate with some of the most
interesting highly intelligent and
talented people from all over the world
and i've always carried around an
ideabook where i wrote down every single
original idea
hold up bro a thousand ideas is a lot
that's super cool and those ideas are
valuable but it depends who's gonna buy
it and why that was my friend logan paul
who's been kind enough to kind of guide
me through this process i then cut out
all thousand ideas pasted them to a wall
in my studio and took a high quality
image of it so the mint is the high
quality image and as an incentive to buy
you get to collaborate with me on one of
your favorite thousand ideas which will
also be sent to the buyer as a digital
file of the listed thousand ideas i then
spoke to some big brands and agencies
that i work with to put a value like in
actual cash
on what the thousand original ideas plus
the collaboration with me as a director
or youtuber on my channel
would be worth and that's a sale i could
make right now not using the nft
platform point i'm trying to make here
is that ideas in the creative world are
currency
but are they valued as highly in the nft
space step two marketing
from skillshare and from logan i got
told that when it comes to nfts
marketing is everything i then shot and
edited a 50 second video of me
explaining the whole story about me
having these thousand ideas that would
be auctioning off over the next three
days on open c starting at the lowest
bid of zero step three
the marketplace
then i created an account on openc which
is like this big space for nft sales you
then link your digital wallet to this
add your mint and just before you click
to go live you gotta execute the
marketing material you made in step two
youtube shorts first and send you that
link
[Music]
processing uh
instagram
ah you posted [ __ ] here goes
feels like i'm uploading my first
youtube video ever okay
we are live you're no one spitted yet
[ __ ] sex man i don't know if this is
normal maybe it takes time
okay youtube shortstone instagram dan
and still no bids
what are you doing i'm stressing out
i know nothing about the space i don't
think we're doing this right
i thought it was a cool video
trying to figure it out
[Music]
update it's been
two hours and 22 minutes and i have
uploaded the marketing video to youtube
shorts instagram reels instagram stories
facebook linkedin tick tock reddit we
currently stand
on 0.34
[Music]
ethereum which i mean it's not bad but
it's just so it's not good
okay last night some crazy [ __ ] went
down someone raised the bid to 1.3
ethereum
and then another bid came in at 2.2
which is six thousand five hundred
dollars but then just before i came in
this morning that same bidder then
dropped to one point six nine which is
four thousand seven hundred and thirteen
dollars
it's been 26 hours since the auction
went live and
i've just started realizing that the
marketing it just isn't working the
filmmaking community they're just not
responding to me creating nfts yeah and
logan left me with some pretty good
advice as well since you're generally
inactive in the nft space not much of a
collector haven't been very vocal about
it yourself so i don't think anyone's
like turning to dan mace for like mft
stuff and unfortunately creative ip is
uh only valuable to creatives which is
extremely
limited of an audience like these are
the people who know and love you
obviously but um
yeah like how many how many people
actually want to go out and make stuff
you know especially videos is super nice
so after all of this before this bidder
goes away or even lowers his bid i'm
gonna cash out the offer currently sits
at
1.69 ethereum which is four thousand
seven hundred and thirteen us dollars
i'll add the rest of the dollars to make
it a five thousand dollar amount
to be able to give to you
look four thousand seven hundred dollars
is a [ __ ] ton of money but being a
normal human being and knowing that i
could have sold the same thing
elsewhere for ten times more the price
that feeling sucks it's i'm just being
honest it's
you know however i am really really
grateful to the buyer who i'm just about
to click accept on and i really look
forward to seeing what you do with the
thousand ideas and how you execute them
and then when you pick your favorite one
i mean well we'll be in comms and we'll
collaborate cool i'm going to click
accept
first nft sale ever
complete
done
okay before ending this video and
telling you more about skillshare i just
want to ask you some questions one what
are your thoughts on this nft space as a
whole and two what would have you done
differently than what i did what
approach would have you taken to
maximize your earnings cool more about
skillshare firstly if you click on the
link in the top of my description using
the code danmace you'll get a one month
free trial of skillshare skillshare is
an online learning community with
thousands of inspiring classes for
anyone who loves to learn who wants to
learn something new and to explore their
creativity so yeah do yourself a favor
and invest in yourself if you have a
specific skill you want to learn
skillshare is the perfect place to start
it's super easy to find classes that
match your goals and interests like
becoming creative an artistic guide to
creativity by brent everston it is also
100 ad-free so you can stay in the zone
while learning new skills don't forget
that i'm giving away 5 000 us dollars to
one person that subscribes to my channel
turns their notifications bar on shares
this video across their platforms likes
the video and then comments below
letting me know that you've done so
that's it yeah other than that don't
forget you're awesome brew and i will
see you next week
[Music]